[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you look like you [ __ ] good no
[Laughter]
no no i [ __ ] like my comedy it's stiff
it's quick
yeah it's not pretty not much of an
ending no closer yeah
yeah i'm working on it but it's it's fun
though still huh sex yeah yeah sure
you know i still get to i'm still you
know and as a 50 year old man almost 50.
i still when i'm doing it in my mind i'm
always i'm like a teenager yeah i think
to myself i can't believe i'm doing this
i feel the same way
right and then when they wake up but no
in a theater you ever watch a scary
movie in a theater sure do you ever
scream
you're a man because you're a man
i don't know it's just
yeah i don't let it out yeah i do i'm a
vocal kind of a guy how do you keep it
in yeah like how do you express fear or
being like
i don't i try not to express anything
wait wait
when you
are you quiet oh yeah
will you close your mouth well
this voice is not conducive
getting a vagina wet like if you were if
you had to say something what would you
say
yeah
take it
you would like it [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
my girl likes a real
real insult oh she likes insults yeah
but then if i do it in the kitchen she
hates it you're a skater i was i mean
i'm old now but yeah but so back because
you know i grew up
as a second all right don't please don't
please don't all right i'm a poser uh
please don't please even opened up a
skate shop but can't skate uh i opened
up a skate shop right
[Music]
yeah
come on man come on man look at my body
well that's now you're 61.
yeah whoever said hey don't raise him
i'm joking you look great even though
you're coming out of your shirt at the
bottom
[Laughter]
do you want to do acting or anything
like i can't act
it's not good
i just don't care
i had to do a i've done a million i've
done a million auditions i've never
gotten one and i had to do one where my
dad died next to me on the couch and
they threw me out of the room
that bad oh really like get out of here
what are you doing
yeah i was like oh dad what are you
crazy
are you dying on us yeah geez louise
yeah yeah they're like all right you're
wasting our time i was like i drove here
from santa monica took three hours yeah
so anyway we were in the theater and i
screamed we're watching this movie
hereditary do you see it oh no too
scared
what i saw
mid-summer or oh yeah yeah the same same
guy
yeah so i couldn't watch the other one
oh
wow well you should see it's very good
it's too heavy man that stuff bugs me
i don't want to be scared when you watch
three amigos yeah
i like three amigos
okay yeah all right
yeah yeah yeah i screamed and then the
lady and the couple in front of us goes
can you keep it down you know what i
mean if you're going to scream like that
watch it at home what'd you say
watch it at home and i'm like this is
part of it yeah and we we almost got a
fistfight afterwards
we waited until the they knew that we
were sitting in back of them and the
movie ended and the credits rolled down
and everyone would left the theater
except us four
right so her and i just sat there and we
stared stared at the back of their heads
and as soon as the lights came out oh my
god he turned around and like
what yeah but then we went he drew first
blood which is a mistake art of war yeah
what he did or you did
oh they cussed us out we're angry
don't make a [ __ ] angry yeah yeah you
know that old saying sure
they'll proverb that you get from the
portuguese
i know shane gillis
we've never really crossed paths but
i've been a fan from afar you know he's
a very funny stand-up and um he's doing
very well for himself and um he's done
all the late night shows you know
podcasts done all of them he's um
he's great
and his name is mark norman give him a
round of applause
[Music]
finally somebody talk about how hard the
white man's got it
yeah thank you wow that was very nice
and weird and i can't take a compliment
but i appreciate why why can't you take
a compliment well i don't trust asians
but no
no
it's weird thank you it means a lot yeah
yeah thanks thank you but you have to
admit though that it is
you but you know you know that the
culture is changing sure worse and so
i'm not really supposed to say it but i
know you're not supposed to say i'm just
gonna tell you it well we talk about it
at the meetings
all right the white meetings that you
have yeah yeah who's at those white
meetings the rallies you know it's uh
are there other comments there yeah it's
me owen benjamin and a couple other guys
no yeah yeah yeah do you ever run into
owen no i don't know i don't know i
don't really know him but mark you have
to admit though
you you're doing well
it's going well finally like i'm selling
tickets well you know the game has
changed i've done 13 late nights and all
this [ __ ] nobody cares wow you three
podcasts and people like hey who's this
guy
that's that's how it goes now and this
this op what is this this uh
ck screen here and just in case
it's nice yeah
how do i say this sing it i think
if i was gay yeah which i'm not
jeremy
um that i would find you to be cute oh
thanks you're cute too
[Music]
i just i just want to let that sink in
yeah i mean
just let the silence speak for itself
there was a character on the thundercats
that you look like i love thundercats
yeah the little i think you're nervous
under because it was intimate what we
were doing it wasn't anyone to talk over
it i had to get out of it
i want you to look at me right now
don't get out of it all right all right
i'm gonna slide back in
say
tell me that i'm cute again right oh god
look at my eyes you don't talk for 30
seconds hold on i can't find your eyes
and you count them okay all right
very funny very much but no you're cute
thank you
your feet aren't even hitting the you're
talking adorable you're talking all
right right see you're cute again and
don't say anything all right ready but
lock eyes off guys
say you're cute
[Laughter]
i can't [ __ ] good
i don't [ __ ] good and she knows it
you know what i'll admit i admit to this
i don't i [ __ ] sloppy
you don't do that with the sloppy can be
good
thank you so much and that's why i like
you yeah i think he just [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] weird [ __ ]
weird could be good how do i [ __ ]
um so
maximum 11 and a half pumps maximum
wow
but that half that half is extra it's
like super long because i only i ca i
only want to do 10.
right so i don't you know at 10 i'm like
i'm out he's out
and i go i gotta go that extra one you
know yeah but the question is between
you two who has more body hair
it depends where what part of the body
come again what part of the body yeah uh
nipples yeah oh that's a that's a great
question it might be my [ __ ] has more
hair
i have to admit that
because i have hair in the inside as
well oh yeah yeah so that's why in my
hair
my hair distribution as annie letterman
calls it is very um chemo patient
it's like it's a little patchy yeah it's
scarce in the front i call it chernobyl
yeah yeah yeah yeah very chernobyly yeah
yeah um okay the hair are you hairy no
yeah
i could use a little and i've had
ptsd in those rooms
yeah when you sign up right you're in a
hallway with a bunch of folding chairs
you sit there and people who look like
you people they all look like you
they're wearing hawaiian shirts or
whatever it might be right yeah yeah and
then you're just kind of like they call
your name and you rehearsed it for two
days yep right and as you stand up it
all yeah yeah it all just it's gone so
good right because you know i mean you
and then you start panicking yes and
then you start unfolding your sides on
the walk into the room yeah because you
oh it all slipped away oh and this is
the juke hunt behind the desk going
she's eating uh she's eating noodles
like all right
38 hundredths guy she saw that day right
and then it's like all the stuff that
you memorized that you knew inside and
out is so gone that now you're reading
it off the page right yeah and then
they're like you know um
thank you yeah it's over like that it's
over like that you walk and then there's
a
feeling
when you leave and you get your car
that's so demoralizing man did you nail
that yeah yeah but i'm saying to you i
just got a shitty feeling
because i know that feeling yeah yeah i
know i know and i because i'm telling
you when you were talking about your
thing is all the things that i've i've
lived through wow at the end of the day
though i have to say to you that you
will get one ah that's what my agent
said
damn it yeah yeah let me say something
to you mark norman all right all right i
was on the wrestling team in high school
get out of here
what what
come on wait a minute you were wrestling
with your sexuality
i was on the team [ __ ] can we pull
that up there i don't have it
is there online yeah yeah bobby lee
picture because there's a picture of him
with his varsity pick like and the
wrestling yeah yeah oh you should have
fought ben askren
i think i could beat him
that's just paul thank you same oh yeah
yeah yeah do you see that fight yeah
that was wild
whoa look how hot you were that's me and
that's my brother my brother and i were
both wrestlers oh my god look at the
definition of my arms bro pretty good
yeah pretty solid i mean i was 16.
yeah yeah so anyone else hard what about
your parents
they're more uh they're not against it
but they just didn't care
okay i'll take it better it's saturday
yeah it's more like i'm gonna go to new
york and be a stand-up there i just
don't die you know all right
which i'm fine with but i'm sure when
they watch you on tv now now it's a
different uh different tune yeah what is
it what's now it's like the tune you
know they're telling friends and they're
they're bragging and they're putting me
on their social media
kind of weird
like i grew up with a scary dad and he
started taking antidepressants and now
he's like nice dad oh so he's like how
you doing i'm like go
my dad was the same thing my dad would
go months and six months with being
completely
kind well you would work you know we'd
hardly see him sure and he would drink
and that and then
and they'd be oh it's fine and then six
months
later you know i mean my mom's missing
teeth you know what i mean he gets
now i'm being realized oh really
oh jesus
wait your mom was a meth head
holy [ __ ]
i was crushed in a car
right did you walk away and go to delta
yeah yeah i walked away went to del taco
what a badass yeah and then when it came
back
um the ambulance goes hey sir stand back
and i go why there's a
dead body in that car
and i go oh that's my car
and i had a taco on my head like
that's my guitar
you crawled out of there
yeah am i in trouble
like i'm a survivor man damn
one time on accident ralphie may sat on
me
[Laughter]
this is what i did when i was 23 and i
held on a lot to like my mom just beat
me up my whole life
um i needed to reclaim my power so i i
offered to duel her in a wrestling match
because she had beaks she had been she's
still so physically superior by the way
she has like really 16 packs she's right
she's ripped
like she does she did um competitions
her whole life so she was like a fitness
person like sarah connor sarah like
literally
even to this day she's 60 and has bigger
muscles than all of us in this room like
she's what she's a beast but when i was
23 i was like let's wrestle uh-oh and
i needed to and we did we locked in
and we separated and then she charged me
and all i had to do was move and her
head went through a window what and she
cut herself and that was it there was no
more like i was no longer traumatized i
was like i have you you guys have all
this and you're scared of coven
girl vaccinated all right all right
the girl this is a girl from my island
in the philippines she's from cebu bobby
and i watch her
all day my follower i love her yeah yeah
oh really yeah is she girl good or good
good she's good good
i think she's good but i i don't have i
don't know so i think she
you know i hate to say this and maybe
you can scream at me right now yes all
right screen memory right now and i like
that point um you're joking i i get it
but yeah immediately
i know but there is
like i catch myself going like because
when i see someone like do you watch mma
at all yeah i love mmo right so when you
watch like someone like yona yanchez
amanda nunez or even rose nami eunis
right yeah they i always say they fight
like guys
right right you know and it's it's a
strange thing like everything they do is
like
clean jab jeremy and movement and
sometimes you'll see you know a female
and
i'm gonna get a [ __ ] lint for this
but sometimes you'll see a female mma
fighter and she you know that's how yeah
punches yeah of course they punch like
yeah a girl does in a bar right
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]